Here are three painless ways to negotiate a better deal.
Number one: Just ask and ask nicely.
Many times, salespeople have the ability to give you an extra discount,...
...so simply say to the salesperson or store manager that you're on a tight budget...
...and you want to know if they could do a better deal on the price.
Odds are they'll knock a few dollars off the price.
Number two: Go for the volume discount.
If you're thinking about buying more than one of something,...
...see if the store can give you a discount for buying multiple items.
Finally, offer to pay cash.
Ask if the store could give you a better deal if you pay cash.
This trick works for contractors, but also many independently-owned stores...
...that are burdened with credit card fees...
...might be willing to give you a better price for cash.